neon all right apex slides around and
she shoots
like sith lightning out of her hands
that just seems super fun it also seems
really bad she's like the absolute worst
duelist and she's super fun to play so
neon is our f tier oh you want her f
tier she is the worst agent in the game
is she not i personally think so she has
to be after right raised i think rey's
is
eight here eight's here okay i think
that she is a amazing duelist if you are
a raised player i love the space she
creates i think she's eightier thinks
she's really good sova this is the
easiest one yes if sova is not ester
then no one is estimated the essence
silva stands for s tier sages
are you okay saying that i know you're
such a sage sim i think i've made peace
with the fact that when they made the
last nerf onto her i just laughed i'm
gonna say seat here i agree